les deux multimilliardaires de la
Silicon Valley seront-ils bientôt
adversaires sur un ring le patron de
Twitter Elon Musk a défié celui de
Facebook Mark Zuckerberg un combat en
octogone ironique ou pas qui traduit
leur rivalité économique le fondateur de
méta s'apprête en effet à lancer un
réseau social concurrent au petit oiseau
bleu ce qu'est l'on musk n'a pas manqué
de tac les gentiment sur Instagram Mark
Zuckerberg a répliqué en demandant
l'adresse de leur futur duel tout en s'y
préparant activement rendez-vous a
priori à Las Vegas
[Musique]
avec ces trois buvettes Hervé espère
faire du chiffre la mise en bière c'est
là ouais
je sais de quoi je parle
car les mises en bière Hervé sales
connait
dans la vie il est croque-mort
vous en avez ras-le-bol la fiscalité
absolument pas
c'est donc
de payer les tâches qu'on paye en France
et je dis
à Madame l'avocate que je considère
précise dans la tête
personne ne permettrait de dire ça de
vous donc c'est la même chose du coup je
manque pas de respect je vous offrir
tout de suite un cadeau un an de pouvoir
d'achat ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire
que pour vous ce soir j'ai 4000 euros
net d'impôts pendant 12 mois vous
imaginez aucun souci d'argent pendant un
an du coup ça tue un peu le reste de
votre argument c'est ça le voyez parce
que
on n'est pas là pour insulter les gens
mais non
entre Olivier Truchot madame Salma même
même Mourad qui allait avoir beaucoup
je trouve que c'est c'est presque
indécent c'est presque indécent sur qui
on va aller
accident du travail j'ai jamais trouvé
que gagner de l'argent en France est
indécent absolument pas je n'ai
absolument rien contre ça parce que je
trouve indécent c'est de constamment
dire que les jeunes sont des fainéants
que les fonctionnaires sont des
fainéants
j'ai dirigé une entreprise pendant 30
ans je sais ce que c'est d'accord quel
que soit les problèmes je les connais
c'est la dernière fois que je fais le
jeune dans cette émission je tiens à
vous le dire il est complètement déchiré
là je sais pas si vous avez vu et allez
encore une émission de Camille Combal va
présenter
si vous n'êtes pas content de ce système
il faut quitter le pays
ah bon d'accord la nature est la horreur
du vide il y aura toujours des gens
intelligents pour prendre la suite
je pense pardon
après mais moi je vous jure
aujourd'hui Mourad j'en suis moi à ma
58e chignon donc je vais pas mais je me
plains pas de ça
et après ils ont commandé les deux
dernières les trois bouteilles là
et ils veulent pas le Facebook
les deux hommes ont réglé plus de 10000
euros mais il leur reste 6500 euros à
payer ils ne se sont privés de rien
champagne dès qu'il a plus de 2000 euros
pièce à ce prix là le sombrero est
offert par la maison en quittant
l'aéroport nous croisons un robot chargé
de verbaliser les voitures mal garées il
fonctionne grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle sans qu'aucun humain ne le
contrôle
quand l'alarme retentit le conducteur à
30 secondes précises pour démarrer sinon
le robot enregistre la plaque
d'immatriculation et envoie-la demande
directement chez lui c'est pas les mêmes
factures que les miennes
visiblement la situation amuse les deux
touristes à croire que c'est le petit
jeu qu'ils ont trouvé pour pimenter leur
soirée mais Jérémy n'a pas de temps à
perdre
ils ont payé comment le réseau
d'addition
suspect et oui par le policier
et bientôt une autre machine si on aura
les rues de Singapour
un robot patrouilleur lui aussi guidé à
100% par l'intelligence artificielle il
voit tout reconnaît les passants
repère un colis suspect et peut même
envoyer son propre drone si nécessaire
dans ce pays tout le monde est surveillé
tout le temps et partout et on paye nos
problèmes ok c'est bon allez carte
devant l'insistance de Julien les
touristes s'exécutent
allez
content de leur coup ils vont même
laisser un joli pourboire en prime
durée depuis plus d'une heure
je vous laisse ouvrir qu'y a-t-il à
l'intérieur
Laurence ne vous suicidez pas tout de
suite
j'ai envie de
c'est mort
dans le même état que Marc quand il
croise quelqu'un en pantacourt qu'est-ce
qu'on est en train de payer en ce moment
on est en train de payer 40 ans
d'immigration débridée massives et qu'on
arrive plus à juguler tu fais toujours
les mêmes constats et les mêmes liaisons
l'immigrations immigration laïcité
immigration en fait je savais pas
d'immigration ce serait Alice au pays
des merveilles la France c'est dingue je
pense mais tu te rends compte de
l'analyse simpliste que tu as mais je
veux dire je pense que les fraisiers
sont plus intelligents que ça quand même
moi j'ai pas envie d'être assimilé à
l'extrême droite quoi tout simplement
Pascal Praud Pascal Praud c'est
l'extrême droite non disons que c'est
pas l'extrême droite évidemment il est
trop intelligent Pascal et trop cultivé
et pour être d'extrême droite c'est
parce que je veux dire ce que je veux
dire c'est que ce que ça le ressenti de
la chaîne il est extrêmement campagne
oui bah ils ont défendu Zemmour c'est
franchement et là ils font campagne pour
pour Marine Le Pen selon toi oui il faut
campagne pour l'extrême droite mais bon
c'est pas interdit
de ma mère
mère que tu m'as bien reconnu tu es une
grosse voilà elle m'a pas mis
de feuilles barbecue